welcome to this video playing meta boy
soul mate ah boy soul from um majha tina
c4 here ok now maybe six I often play
with define the structure but this is
six some setup is not so bad it looks a
bit weird maybe but it's some
surprisingly resilient this is one idea
intensifying the pressure on deform so
white quite often fits in client to take
on the hive or play III because yeah
well if I can take on c4 it's not so
easy to defend deform so very often Lee
three years of or captures is so played
yep and then one important problem my
bishop ian is immediately improved ok
I don't mind that I mean it's always
nice to have the the two bishops but
it's also nice to get them this knight
on c6 reroute it which is always a bit
awkwardly placed not always but most of
the time you will see six and maybe
night f5 to d6 this is all I always I'm
an interesting thing to consider putting
the night on d6 hmm ok flick in this
move
okay so I'll take this chance taking on
d4 first now dropping this back that
very often is a good square in Queens
gambit exchange structures and this is a
queen's gambit exchange instructor also
commonly known as the cards but
structure from this is coming from this
tournament that was played in the 1920s
in the nowadays check city of Carlsbad
well nowadays it's a mantis got a
different name at some it's a karlovy
novi something like that probably
terribly butchering the pronunciation
but it it has lost some German name of
course oh ok what what now 95 mmm not so
clear what it is doing really let's
let's a complete development it's also
considering that's a queen EA Denton
time attacking it directly maybe he
wants to I'm what's to go to d3 hmm ok
d3 to c5 I didn't really address that
idea ok well now I can consider too I
know I cannot assure that should
actually take i have d for now amongst
others deform or the night first the
night 94-95 ok this was my initial idea
and I'm going for that this Knight d2
threatened and the e5 pawn is saying
before I'm not sure that it really helps
me much
this just looks nice getting the pawn oh
really okay well d 4 i'm in a pin yeah i
know it still looks awkward i can even
take can even take now we're not
actually I mean maybe maybe not because
I had something better that's Platts
possible but it wasn't bad hmm okay all
the Queen needs to move of course but
way out maybe here Queen take this
Bishop f5 and tea mmm yeah maybe Bishop
a five as well or Bishop g4
okay let's play a good developing move
first and then decide what to do now
Bishop g4 is a bit stronger i believe
the idea okay Bishop g4 look you won
some really annoying pin okay you know
it's um it's a young it's a pawn but
it's also not easy c5 is just a very
nice spot for the night
check trying to activate here with nida
three young bishop f3 his rook does not
have so many good squares really squares
the dome running into this and ya know I
can actually do that Knight f3 it's
really so great at the end I'm chat ok
not much choice community five I thought
Queenie five ok or maybe this is better
it's possible ok so my idea was of
course to to get this this excellent
bishop on d5 but he can of course take
here on b7 I have queen bee too though
taking before all the rook the rook
actually why not the rook time morning
rook ph maybe queenie queenie seven
looks completely unhuman move allowing
queen of three it's a bit of a gamble
after Queen a7 I can move the rook to
see eight or something just hoping that
yeah that is not not going for that
night a six there is a rookie form and
this should be very good maybe there's
the check and 97 now hmm now this could
be a problem oh this could also be a
problem and no rookie eight major 97's
queen of three at least i'm not sure
what this is is this a draw or is this
is this a win
I'm not sure white resides Wow why I
want too stupid to see it I back into I
can go to be two with check but still
this is so still I still needed to find
this and the sack this is seems to be a
win with check this coming okay and then
then the rook yeah okay I probably would
have found it but still Wow and this was
some very tough first of all I'd like to
know what's happening here the computer
wants to do rook to diate okay not it
well 97 I must admit I just overlooked
we can play 97 oh wow mmm nicer I wow I
simply overlooked this and this also
means the rock da deserve it the must
really must play yeah this this losses
but ok it's a it's just blitz with low
seconds on the clock Queen III seems to
be right here very complicated affair
probably probably has sported somewhere
here I mean not spoiling it in terms of
losing but not playing the the best
possible yeah default was better after
all okay the idea being that after could
we move i can even advanced um now okay
this is so this is better okay now he
really gets lots of activity especially
the night coming to c5 is a huge problem
it it makes my life rather
rather difficult check the key around
here this probably room for improvement
okay it's um there are limits to what
you can do in blitz the idea must play
repudiate and then it's at least up at
least the playable position something
like this it's not clear at all I guess
well yeah complicated um thanks for
watching